hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another video today I want to talk about
one of my favorite tools that are used
to run in business it's a tool called
time trade and it helps me plan all of
my meeting so if it's an in-person
meeting or if it's a by phone meeting I
love the system seems me lots of time so
if i go to time trade here this is my
page of my favorite tools i'll load this
one up and tell you a little bit about
why i like it and how i use it and
hopefully there's some applications if
you'd use it in your business as well so
this is the page i'm going to log in so
you can see more what it looks like on
the back end if you do end up getting it
as an account now i signed up for the
paid version of this but i'll show you
kind of what it goes through so what it
is it connects to your calendar so for
me it says here it's connected to my
google calendar and it looks for spots
that i have open to my calendar and will
help me book meetings and phone calls
when I want to set it up so i use it for
sin up coffee x phone calls and also i
do some salsa lessons for people who are
competing in salsa competitions so i'll
talk mostly about the coffee and phone
call because that relates to my business
so what it does and so i can click on
coffee important with evan for example
what it does allows me to book 60
minutes of time in person meeting at
tells people where they're going to go
so it's a starbucks at this location so
i have all my meetings at this location
people come to me to me to help save on
my travel time and it also helps me do
back-to-back meetings and i have people
enter and why are we meeting so it's
important because if we book the time in
advance and we have a meeting you know
three weeks later i'll probably forget
what's going on so it enables them to
enter that information in which is great
it allows me to book eight weeks in the
future and i could change all this and
tells me how much time i have available
so when you're setting one of these up
you can call it whatever you want this
is what people will see and you have to
tell them kind of where you're going
this is going to be an in-person meeting
and if you click on the appointment
availability this is what allows you to
integrate with your calendar so for me I
don't have that many time salts
available I try not to do meetings in
general
or phone calls I try to avoid them
because it can be a huge time suck but
when i do do them it's usually thursday
afternoon so i have two spots open
potentially for people who want to do
coffee meetings here that's you know a
potential available then order taken up
and then i'll use the same spots for
phone calls so allows me to get all my
meetings done in one chunk of time so it
can be extra kind of productive on that
and can go from one meeting to another
or one minute to a phone call back to
another meeting whatever we want so
it'll basically look at my calendar and
if I don't have anything booked for this
time it'll give it as an option for
people who want to book a time with me
if you want to see an example of what it
looks like I can click here as a link
and this is the link that you would then
be able to send people and so when
people want to meet with me they'll get
this link and it will show them
basically the time spots that I have
open and the information that they need
to put in so they'll say you're
scheduling this is for phone call up to
30 minutes I always call people instead
of them calling me because I'm always on
time and often people are not and if you
only have 30 minutes in time you want to
make sure that you use it productively
so that starts with making the phone
call on time so i can click check
availability it'll show me the dates
that are open so I say okay I want to
talk with Evan on you know the 19th and
it shows you the different times that
are open so you can click one go next
it'll say what number should I die you
so you can say okay my number is
whatever it is because I always do the
phone calling so I need to make sure I
have their number what are we discussing
so again you have to enter in what it is
that you want to talk about and you have
to enter in this information here
otherwise it doesn't allow you to move
forward if this was a meeting they would
tell you the address and where we're at
you can be meeting and if you want you
can even throw in a map if you want or a
picture of yourself and here's what I
look like I
that kind of information you can include
in there as well so this is super
helpful what I also really like about it
is it'll send people a reminder the day
before saying just a reminder you have a
call with Evan tomorrow at three o'clock
or your meeting Evan at this starbucks
at three o'clock tomorrow so that they
remember so again if you're booking I
allow people to book up to eight weeks
out so if you're booking in advance you
simply might come up you forget about it
so it's good to have that reminder
that's automatically built in so I'm not
following up with people myself this I
hey just a reminder we're meeting
tomorrow then when I can do on my admin
side I'll get an email every time
somebody books appointment and it
automatically puts it into my calendar
system so i can see it pop up
automatically there for me and it has
all that information of why we're
meeting what number I'm calling link to
their website etc you can enter in more
criteria if you want to have that I try
to keep it minimal but if you have more
specific criteria they want people that
through and you can put that in there
too you can then look at your opponent
in box you can see who you have meetings
coming up with so now I have a meeting
with John and Arthur coming up I can
click on it for details if i want for
phone calls again i can click on and see
who i have coming up so it's a phone
call again i can click on it so what are
we discussing this 20-minute interview
so it's good you know i may not
recognize the name and then i can see
that oh it's an interview and their
questions attached so that's that's
great for me to be able to you'll
prepare for that in advance of the call
so details of the apartment you can
click on and they'll show okay it's a
20-man interview performance as an
entrepreneur sample questions etc so
I'll have all this information
automatically in my calendar system so
then when it pops up I know what we're
talking about i remember you know why
we're setting this call up and it really
helps me kind of be prepared and this is
all stuff i used to do keep notes very
time consuming and i love using a system
to help me kind of manage all that
myself the next thing I do is if i want
to send an email you can just send out
that link so i use gmail but you can do
it through outlook or whatever you you
know your main email program is as well
if you want to send an email out to
somebody you'll see something like this
pop up
I use canned responses so what I'll do
if somebody wants to set up a phone
meeting with me for example I will go
down in here and say hi John we should
talk and then I'll do kind response
phone meeting and here's the link to my
schedule so we can plan a time remove
that and then if it clicks on that link
he'll be able to schedule time to talk
with me and so I find that to be super
helpful for him and you don't have to
remember what exactly that whole long
link is yourself if you use outlook you
can do it as custom signatures which I
used to do before moving the gmail and
then you know just put the email address
in and send away so it saved me a ton of
time in being able to you know book
appointments keep me on track let me
know what's coming up reminds them
before the meeting that it's happening
again and it's great for them to pick a
time that is convenient for them and I
know is convenient for me into having to
go back and forth and say well how about
this day or this day or this day so I
find it just super helpful saving me
time and and when I only have such
limited time suitably actually talk to
people and meet with people it's helpful
to be able to have a system that saves
us all a bunch of time so that's what I
use it's a 30-day free trial to help you
kind of get get into it and see if you
like it I got hooked through my 30 days
and it ends up being 30 bucks a year if
you want to sign up for it and that's
the professional Edition that you see
here that I'm using it's all the same
functionality your 30 days just limits
you after 30 days so definitely a huge
no time saver definitely worth the 30
bucks a year and I find it extremely
help for my business so hopefully you
guys if you haven't heard of it can
check it out if you guys like the video
I'd love to see some thumbs up below if
you want to leave one and I also would
love to hear if you have any comments or
what you guys use or if you like this
video if you want to leave a comment
underneath so thank you and stay tuned
for next episode
you